congratulations you survived yet another
year in the simulation if you still have
a job in Tech it means you survived
massive layoffs didn't get drafted into
a war and outsmarted the artificial
intelligence that your boss wants to
replace you with 2023 was the craziest
year ever but at the rate things are
accelerating it'll look like nothing
compared to 2024 I care deeply about the
future because I'm going to spend the
rest of my life there but the future
ain't what it used to be in today's
video we'll look at 10 Trends and
technology that you can take advantage
of in 2024 let's get started by looking
at the health of the job market at the
beginning of 23 we had massive layoffs
from Magnificent Seven companies like
Amazon Google and Microsoft not only did
this flood the job market with more
talent but simultaneously the number of
open jobs declined by about 60% Based on
data from true up.i and that's been a
onetwo punch to the nuts for junior
developers looking to get into the
industry in 2021 we had people working
multiple full-time jobs simultaneously
thanks to remote work and you could land
these jobs by simply taking a 100 second
boot camp but today things look look a
lot different managers are still
desperately trying to get people back
into the office and you can find all
kinds of anecdotes on Reddit about how
brutal the job market is right now it's
been a rough year but there is some hope
if we look closely at the chart you'll
notice that job openings are up 13.8%
from earlier this year and all the Big
Fang companies have unfrozen their
hiring freezes although there aren't
nearly as many open jobs as there used
to be so I'd be cautiously optimistic
about an improving job market going into
2024 but a lot of that depends on the
state of the world we're still in a high
interest rate environment which is not
ideal for cash burning startups that
need that easy money to hire a bunch of
people to grow quickly just yesterday
Spotify did its third layoff of the Year
where it severed about, 1500 heads which
it blamed on the higher cost of capital
these high rates have also put the real
estate market at a standstill
dramatically reducing the total number
of transactions because nobody wants to
pay $900,000 for a cardboard box with an
8% mortgage the automotive industry is
also struggling and we saw Tesla prices
come way down in 2023 which was a shock
to some people who thought their Tesla
was an appreciating asset just a year
ago the economy and especially
technology is addicted to low rates but
we've also got some Wars going on now I
don't stand with Palestine I don't stand
with Israel I don't stand with Ukraine I
don't stand with Russia I stand with
locked Martin and Boeing and the
military industrial complex these
companies make the tools we need to blow
each other up and when you stand with
that team you really can't lose what you
have to realize is that you're living
paycheck to paycheck your employer is
living bailout to bailout and the United
States government is living from war to
war if we don't get a big war soon the
entire system could collapse and that's
not going to bode well for tech jobs in
the future but speaking of money crypto
is back Bitcoin was 16k at the beginning
of the year and just broke 40K a couple
days ago and crypt Bros are already
predicting that one token will be worth
over a million dollars by the end of
2024 the price to watch for is 69k if it
reaches this price point the world will
be flooded with memes that will Elevate
fomo to biblical levels in other words
the crypto winter might be over bringing
us a fresh new round of Ponzi schemes to
invest our parents money in another
failed technology that could come back
in 2024 is augmented and virtual reality
thanks primarily to the Apple Vision Pro
which is set to release in early 2024
Apple has done some revolutionary things
in the past like a mouse that charges
from the bottom and if these VR goggles
take off it could lead to a whole new
round of opportunity for app developers
however I think that's unlikely plenty
of Apple Colt members will drink this
Kool-Aid but I don't think the general
public is going to Fork over $3,500 to
become even more disconnected from
reality ultimately though I think this
will end up being a niche product very
cool to some people but not appealing to
the average NPC now speaking of Hardware
Microsoft just announced a few weeks ago
that it's going to start producing its
own chips like the Maya chip for
artificial intelligence and the Cobalt
CPU which is an arm-based processor
designed for general purpose use in the
cloud and AWS is also building its own
Arm based chips which are cheaper and
more efficient than traditional x86
chips now as of today virtually all PCS
and laptops running Windows run CPUs
based on the x86 architecture but that
may not be the case in the future
because thanks to project vola it's now
possible to run Windows on arm chips
hell even Intel is going to start
manufacturing arm chips the sing single
most important thing anyone does with a
CPU though is play video games and just
yesterday we got our first look at the
GTA 6 trailer this will likely be the
most hyped up video game in the history
of the world and it's built using
Rockstar's own proprietary rage game
engine and that means you can't use it
what you can use is Unity however Unity
made a massive blender in 2023 by
rolling out new pricing that would
charge developers every time a game is
downloaded Unity developers revolted and
it got so bad that they had to roll back
the pricing and apologize that's right
apologize meanwhile unreal and release
version 5.3 with some crazy new features
like a procedural content generation
framework and its substrate material
system that gets almost
indistinguishable from reality now
unreal engines parent company epic games
sued Apple a few years ago saying it's a
monopoly because it takes a 30% cut on
the App Store and doesn't allow
alternative payment methods but it lost
that suit and that was held up on appeal
in 2023 epic games is not giving up
though with a similar ongoing lawsuit
against Google it seems like a long shot
but if they somehow win it would be huge
for Indie developers because they could
avoid that 30% cut to the big guy by
using their own payment processor but
now let's talk about web development
JavaScript land is as crazy as ever but
I think in 2024 people will stop
building new JavaScript Frameworks
because nowadays they all have a similar
developer experience with signal-based
reactivity and the race will shift to
who can build the best tools for
existing Frameworks we're seeing more
visual editors and idees for Frameworks
like react where you can drag and drop
components instead of coding them
manually then you have Frameworks like n
which have built-in Dev tools to make
life easier but pretty soon we should
have ai writing most of our code there
are tools like visual co-pilot where you
can take a design in figma and it will
automatically write the framework code
along with Tailwind Styles in the near
future I think every JavaScript
framework will have its own specialized
tooling along with its own specially
tuned AI for writing useful accurate
code whichever framework does this the
best will win the web development War
for the next 10 years and I think there
will be a lot of opportunity on the web
in part because of Trends in Mobile
development this trend has been ongoing
for many years but people just don't
want to download mobile apps anymore
it's not like 10 years ago when you
could develop an app in your mom's base
have it go viral and become a
millionaire overnight there are billions
of people using smartphones every day
but getting their attention away from
established apps is harder than ever
like as you can see here most of my
screen time goes to Twitter and Discord
when it comes to building mobile apps
not too much has changed but if you're
building crossplatform we're starting to
see more locode tools that can build for
both IOS and Android with a drag and
drop interface but now let's talk about
low-level systems languages rust is
still growing incredibly fast and you
can now find Rust code in the Linux
kernel there was some drama with the
rust Foundation earlier this year and I
might get sued for using this logo but
there are some other upand cominging
low-level languages as well like Zig the
language behind the JavaScript bun
runtime and also Mojo a python superet
that can also handle low-level memory
management making it both approachable
and extremely performant an ideal option
for AI and machine learning and finally
that brings us to number 10 the elephant
in the room artificial intelligence chat
GPT has only been around for a year
although it feels like a lot longer and
most normies out there haven't even
touched it yet but that's going to
change over the next few years because
we now have Bard built into Google to
cannibalize its own search engine we
have co-pilot built into Microsoft
Office to write all your papers and do
all your spreadsheets an estimated 75%
of all stock trading now happens via
algorithms and AI is being weaponized to
both launch and defend against cyber
attacks and even our military-industrial
complex friends like paler are using AI
to help blow people up in a more
environmentally friendly and Equitable
way but things got really crazy with
generative image AI 10 years ago Ian
goodfella published a paper proposing
the first generative adversarial Network
7 years later open AI brought us to
Fusion models with Dolly but they still
sucked pretty hard but then just two
years from that point we get images good
enough to make $110,000 a month on only
fans in 2024 a big Trend to watch is
text to video stable diffusion just
released a text to video model and at
the current rate of progress I predict
that by the end of 2024 you'll be able
to generate a fulllength Bollywood
quality movie from your laptop but none
of this will matter if somebody first
achieves artificial general intelligence
an AI that can actually think for itself
and not just regurgitate and remix
things humans have already done some
people even think this has already been
achieved by open AI with the leak of qar
however there's a french guy that thinks
AGI is decades away and some think it
will never be achieved when that day
comes it could be a great day for
Humanity we'll never have to work or
think again and there will be nothing
left to do but indulge in pleasure on
the other hand though you may live to
see AI made Horrors beyond your
comprehension it could end up being like
when fa made a deal with the devil for
unlimited knowledge and pleasure but
once that knowledge is achieved there's
a trade-off in the form of moral and
spiritual decline the AI will have to
adjust for this trade-off by creating
billions of lab grown babies which are
now a real thing then put them into a
simulation that has a disproportionate
amount of suffering in order to offset
the pleasures experienced by the AI in
fact you might be in the simulation
right now why else would you be watching
a video gaslighting you into thinking
you're in a simulation you'd have to be
crazy to think we're not in a simulation
right now but again congratulations for
making it to round 2024 thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one